if you loved the new Netflix movie
extraction here are five other movies or
shows totally worth checking out on this
week's binge guide produced by Avengers
and Game directors Joe and Anthony Russo
and starring Thor himself the muscular
version this time Chris Hemsworth
extraction is coming in fresh and
definitely has a lot of people talking
so if you were into this story about a
fearless mercenary rescuing the son of a
crime lord with some six or Fights mixed
in between here's what you should watch
next starting with our certified fresh
pick Black Hawk Down this 2001 film was
directed by Ridley Scott and features
stars like Josh Hartnett and Ewan
McGregor as part of a peacekeeping force
dropped into a civil war torn Somalia to
try and kidnap two top lieutenants of a
local crime lord based on a series of
articles and an eventual book from the
late 90s the critics call this a
visceral pulse-pounding portrait of war
that is elevated by Ridley Scott's
superb technical skill it'll take you to
Stover two and a half hours to watch
which is well worth it considering
you'll learn about a quickly forgotten
chapter in United States military
history and for our throwback pick this
week we're going with Fox's 24 this
exciting and edgy real time action
series about u.s. counter-terrorist
agent Jack Bauer play by Kiefer
Sutherland ran for nine seasons between
2001 and 2014 Sutherland picked up in
Emmy and a Golden Globe throughout the
series run playing what critics called a
compelling hero in a show brimming with
tension and political intrigue it'll
take you one hundred and forty three
hours to binge the whole series but if
you try and keep track of just how many
times Jack Bauer escaped death you'll
never get bored and this week's rotten
pic that we love is going to the 2004
flake man on fire with a strong audience
score of 89% this one star is Denzel
Washington as a burned-out ex CIA agent
brought in to Mexico City as the
bodyguard for a nine-year-old girl after
a wave of kidnappings Denzel is backed
by a supporting cast that includes
Dakota Fanning Christopher Walken and
singer Mark Anthony and critics say this
one starts out well but goes over the
top in the violent second
at a hundred and forty-six minutes
though this one is an easy watch and
will give you many of the same feelings
you got from watching extraction you
know like suspense from the comfort of
your own couch next is our
under-the-radar pic and that's Hotel
Mumbai this film from 2019 stars Armie
Hammer Nazanin Boniadi and Doug Patel
and it vividly recounts the true story
of the Taj Hotel terrorist attack in
Mumbai where hotel staff risked their
lives to keep everyone safe based on
hundreds of hours of interviews with
survivors and witnesses the critics call
this film a well-made dramatization of
tragic events and it just over 2 hours
watch time this one will keep you on the
edge of your seat while giving you a
look at what real-life heroes look like
and for our editor's pick this week
we're recommending tom clancy's jack
ryan this amazon original series is
based on Tom Clancy's CIA operative Jack
Ryan as he begins his career in the spy
game it stars John Krasinski's stepping
into the famous role that has also been
played by big names like Harrison Ford
and Ben Affleck before him the critics
praised this show for its exceptional
action sequences and likable cast and it
has been a strong pillar for Amazon
originals with a third season due out
most likely in 2021 the first two
seasons will take you around 16 hours to
bench alright guys hopefully this will
help get you through your next few binge
sessions and be sure to check back for
more recommendations and ideas based
around other movies and shows that you
guys love right here on the Rotten
Tomatoes binge guide happy Benton
you
[Music]